Hello and welcome to Python Bytes where we deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds. This is episode 96 recorded September 19th
2018 I'm Michael Kennedy and I'm Brian Akin. Hey Brian. How you doing? I'm doing really good. All right, I'm doing great
There's always something to talk about in the Python space and never gets boring
Yeah, no, definitely doesn't and we're here bringing this to you today in part because of Digital Ocean sponsoring this episode
So check them out at Python bytes at FM slash
Digital Ocean and get a hundred dollars credit for some server goodies tell you more about that later.
Brian you found an interesting one i don't even know what to make of it here tell us about it.
I can't remember where i came across this i guess it doesn't matter there's a python library called plumbum and it's.
That spelled plumbum i have no idea where they came up with that name but it's a toolbox of goodies to do shell like things in python.
It says shell combinators and more i'm not sure the combinator is.
Oh there was that white combinator on back to the future other than that i don't know what a combination is like the pipes between things maybe perhaps anyway.
The model library and i'm read this is direct quote is never write shell scripts again.
And thus it attempts to mimic the shell syntax,
oh, shell combinators is shell syntax,
where it makes sense while keeping all the
Pythonic and cross-platform goodiness of Python.
And it's kind of fun and it's one of those things,
it's kind of cheating, actually, I think, but it's cool.
We have an example in the show notes,
but there's a bunch of examples on their website,
on the readme and stuff.
You can do things like chaining commands like with pipes,
and there's a built-in grep and word count and head counts within this library.
So if you've got a bash shell script and somebody says,
"Hey, you should convert that to Python."
This would take you like five minutes to convert it to Python using this.
That's not necessarily a bad thing.
If you know how to transform something here,
you can convert it right away.
Then maybe if you want to go figure out how to do that with other ways,
You could, but for a lot of quick and dirty things,
why not do something like this?
- It looks really cool.
Certainly writing Bash stuff,
the more tests you have to do
and the looping over things,
it's just like, how do you do that in Bash again?
You know, it's just, it's not so nice.
But there's certainly things you can do in the shell
that are painful in Python.
Show me the files here.
It's like, okay, well fine, we're gonna import OS
and we're gonna do a lister and loop over that.
Right, like LS, right?
That's super easy.
And this kind of brings those things together.
It's really nice.
- Yeah, so I've got a couple things
I'm gonna throw this out right away
is we're converting from,
on in Jenkins you can do shell commands
within like the little command steps of Jenkins,
but if you're doing pipelines on Windows
you can't do Bash for some reason,
or I can't figure out a way to do Bash,
but I can do Python.
So I could write a little Python script
to do the thing that I wanted to do in Bash
and do it right there.
So I'll try that.
- Yeah, nice.
So this is a really cool project
and certainly if you're thinking about
some kind of bash script or something like that.
This is a really nice option.
- Maybe I should just try to use the Linux subsystem
on Windows 10 instead of.
- Yeah, so if you have a problem with getting bash to work,
it doesn't work on Windows, right?
But you can definitely bring in
the Windows 10 Linux subsystem.
And obviously that's Windows 10.
I'm sure that it's available
on the Windows Server equivalent of Windows 10,
which I honestly don't even know what version that is,
but there's probably a server equivalent.
that has the Linux subsystem as well.
People can throw that in the show comments if they want.
But there's an article by Marcus Sherman
called the Windows 10 Linux subsystem for Python developers.
First of all, have you heard of this
Windows 10 Linux subsystem?
Do you know what this is?
- Yeah, I've been trying to keep an eye on it
and as they make fixes to it and add features,
I've been trying some of these things out.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
So it's basically Linux embedded inside of Windows.
And you've always been able to run in Windows,
like a VMware virtual machine or something and run say Ubuntu, but that's
not what this is. It's not like a separate, entirely separate running VM, but
it's like a little tiny micro VM type thing that is the command line shell for
Ubuntu. So you can basically have Ubuntu commands and an Ubuntu terminal in your
Windows. The idea is somebody says, "Hey, here is some library you want to use." And
the way you get it is you compile it from source and run it, or you know, you
need to have this other weird utility or type these commands, right? Like how often
have you seen a tutorial that says, "Okay, Brian, the next step is to type Python 3
-m venv.env and then you say source.env bin activate." That's awesome, right? It
works fine on your Mac. It works fine on my Mac. It works fine on my Linux server. Does it
work fine on Windows? No, you have to use the scripts directory. Scripts directory,
There is no Python 3, there is no source.
Like what is all this stuff, right?
It's like, why is it different?
And so the motivation that Marcus had for writing this
is like, hey, if you're gonna learn Python
and you're on Windows,
you might consider using the Ubuntu subsystem
because then all those commands
that everybody tells you to do, they just work.
'Cause it says, hey, look. - Oh, that's a good idea.
- You could use, say, Anaconda, and you get all the tools,
but you still can't type Python 3,
you still can't type source.
Like all these things don't work
unless you run Ubuntu for Windows.
So it's a really nice step-by-step way to go through it,
specifically for setting up for Python development
on Windows.
- Okay, cool, neat.
- Yeah, pretty sweet, right?
So you might say it's a little cheat sheet
for getting Ubuntu working there, right?
- Yeah, hey, we're doing really good
on the whole transition thing.
- Yeah, it's working.
- Yeah, we've got a cheat sheet on my next item.
I've been trying to do type hints a little bit more,
especially, so we've got a lot of people at work
and myself are using PyCharm. And the little pop up dial, I
don't know what that complete drop down type dot, yeah, that
all that stuff works really great. And you it also works
better if you have type hints in your API is just two things. So
I've been trying to do at least for the external functions, I've
been trying to do type hints in there, but I forget some things.
So I ran across this type hints cheat sheet. And it's on the
It's actually on the mypy documentation site.
But the things that, I mean, I remember some of the easy things,
like how do you represent string and int and stuff like that.
But what about duck type stuff?
Like if I have a thing that acts like an array,
but it might be a tuple or it might be a list or it might be something else
that I just know that I need to be able to use the bracket index operator
and find the length.
Well, that's a sequence for type hints.
But I don't always remember that if that's an iterator,
iterable or sequence or things like that.
So those duct type things are what I'm using it
for the most, but I have other people that I work with
that are just sort of learning this type in thing.
So all of it's useful.
- Yeah, and it's not that long.
A scroll bar estimation is probably seven or eight pages.
Flip through that once and you pretty much
have mastered the type ins.
There's a couple interesting things in here
that I thought was nice.
Talking about adding type ins for asynchronous functions,
So async def, the one that I had never seen was class level variables.
So class var looks pretty interesting.
Like it's not on the instance, but it's on the type.
Oh, interesting.
Right?
You can use class var annotation to declare a class variable.
I'd never done that.
I'm just, you know, and that's pretty interesting.
And then also specifying the type for, say, a generator or something that yields some
kind of iterator.
It's pretty interesting.
There's also a generator, actual generator type declaration that takes three arguments
that's not covered in here.
So that's also potentially worth noting.
But yeah, very cool stuff.
And I think this is a nice find.
Cool.
Nice.
Now, before we get on to the next thing, I want to tell you quickly about DigitalOcean.
Like I said, they're sponsoring the show, and they have lots of good reasons to go check
them out.
Something that they just announced that's coming soon and is available for early access
is Kubernetes.
So if you have some kind of site that you would like to run on a Kubernetes cluster,
you can now go first visit pythonbytes.fm/digitalocean, create an account so you get the free $100
credit, and then go to digitalocean.com/products/kubernetes.
And you can sign up for early access to check that out.
So then you can submit containers to run on the Kubernetes cluster and have simple zero
downtime deployments.
That's actually very, very cool.
Yeah, I'm pretty excited about that coming along.
going to be fun. So every now and then we cover these sort of higher level topics
a little softer. Here's one that tries to look a little bit farther in the future
and I'm just gonna put these out there and then I'll let you give me your... you
react to this article. Okay so the overall theme here is that Python is
driving the creation and foundation of new languages. Okay so this was an
article and it says here are five predictions for what programming will
look like in 10 years. Programming will be, okay, so number one, programming will be
more abstract. When I first read that I'm like, oh please don't tell me it's drag
and drop. QML again or something like that, right? But no, they say that trends
like serverless technology, containers, we just talked about Kubernetes, and low-code
platforms suggest that developers may be able to work at higher level of
abstractions in the future, not thinking about servers for example. And that
sounds reasonable. Yeah, to some extent, yeah. Yeah, potentially. AI will become a
a part of every developer's toolkit,
but it won't replace them.
What do you think?
- I don't buy that actually, but okay.
- Get some comment I could say
to some of the voice assistants,
but I'm pretty sure I'll set off like thousands of them,
so I won't do it.
All right, a universal programming language will arise.
- Well, Python, it's already arisen.
- So yeah, so the reason this whole article
was pretty interesting is it has
a pretty strong Python influence.
So for example, at the beginning it says,
"Look, just in the last few years,
some languages have risen and some have fallen and like the have risen links to an interesting article about Python,
have fallen links to an interesting one about Ruby, for example.
And then under this section, there's a nice quote that says,
"Python may be remembered as being the great-great-great grandmother of languages of the languages of the future,
which underneath the hood may look like English, but are actually far easier to use."
Okay. Yeah.
Okay.
Ready for my reaction yet or you got more?
I'm ready. Bring it.
I think some of the things are, one of the jokes about Python sometimes is that it's
a, it's runnable pseudocode.
I don't like it.
I don't actually want it to get closer to English because English has so many subtleties
and weird things that you can do that have implied meaning that the closer we get to
the actual English language, actually the harder it is to actually debug something.
So having it not be that close, I think is better because it's less up for interpretation.
>> Right.
Please read that sentence.
The people over there have already read the red sign.
You know, things like that.
I'm not so sure that a universal language will arise either.
There's always something you may want to take most advantage of and by doing so, you make
it less good for other things.
For example, look at like, say, the data science tool set.
better working with sets of data than individual things.
I don't know, it focuses on one thing,
and so then other things become less easy with it.
All right, so I don't know.
One of the changes which is nice is that
the languages are not being developed in the vacuum that they used to be.
They're learning from each other.
Yeah, that's for sure.
And we're getting the mega cool feature in one language
that we would like to have in another.
We're already seeing that.
Python's taking some features from other languages and pulling it in.
Other features are taking cool languages.
And now if I've heard from a lot of people that
hardly any other languages have good testing tools like pytest.
Specifically, they don't have pytest for other languages.
And that would be cool if we could have some better testing tools in other languages.
So yeah, I mean, there's certainly examples of that, like Swift,
Apple's Swift is very much Python inspired.
you see like the optional, the null coalescing operator being moved towards Python and 3.8 potentially, things like that.
So I agree, I definitely see it as a blending, I don't know if there'll be a single one.
So alright, final two, every developer will need to work with data.
I think that they're doing that now, right?
Yeah, I think that's already, we always have.
Yeah, and then programming will become a core tenant of the education system, like reading and writing.
I believe that.
I do too.
It isn't necessarily like reading and writing. I think it's more like learning biology and basic chemistry.
It's not that you actually need it every day, but it's good that most people kind of understand how it sort of works.
Yeah, I'm totally with you. And the thing I think it will eject from the education system is geometry.
I feel like the reason that geometry is taught in middle school and high school
is so that critical thinking and proof type of logical thought can be taught.
hot. Like you don't really need to prove this thing about isosceles triangles.
Like that doesn't help you in life. But the thought process does. And I feel like
programming, you have the same type of thought processes, but you get a skill
not just a grade. Yeah, my prediction. That's interesting. Yeah. Yeah, we'll see
about that. All right, so another one on async.io, something I've been digging
into a ton lately. Yeah, I wasn't even aware that this was a thing going on. But
apparently the standard library async.io documentation was completely rewritten from scratch recently.
That's awesome. That's big news.
Yeah, it even says it in the tweet announcement. This is big news.
With like two flames on the side.
So I haven't actually read through this a whole bunch, but it does look like there's quite a bit of documentation there.
So that's neat.
That's really cool.
And it says they're not done.
So there's a comment that there's, this is just the beginning, that there's,
they're going to add some tutorials for high level concepts and APIs,
and then they're also going to keep going because apparently there's some new things planned for 3.8.
Yeah, that's awesome. You highlight some of the things coming for async.io itself,
like the library and the capabilities async and await are getting better, right?
Yeah, and I think this sort of talks to the importance of async in the future.
If not only are people still working on making, improving the async story within Python,
but they're also trying to improve the documentation to make sure that it's usable,
which I'm glad to see that sort of documentation going side by side with new concepts.
That's a good thing.
But that kind of highlights the importance of async going forward.
Yeah, I think async is just becoming increasingly important,
and I'm really glad to see it really gaining some momentum
because if you look at apps written with and without async in a library that can take advantage of it,
it's like night and day. It's ridiculous.
I think that, like you said, again, it's a different concept sort of thing.
You can think in higher level concepts and break problems up into the more logical breaking points.
Right. You don't have to think about threads and processes and coordination and all that.
You just say, "I'm going to do this part, then I'll wait, then I'll do that part, then I'll wait, then I'll do that part."
And then, you know, that's sort of that higher level abstraction.
Yeah.
You want to get caught up on all the places that Python is headed?
All the directions? All the threads?
Yeah, definitely.
So there was the 2018 Python Language Summit.
Okay, that's where all the core developers get together and they talk about what they're
doing.
They do proposals to each other like, "Hey, I think we should focus on this," or "We need
to address that," and so on.
And there's some really interesting items.
And on lwn.net, which is a pretty interesting site, they've got a lot of great stuff, mostly
focused on Linux.
It's kind of like the Craigslist of Linux news or something.
I don't know.
design but basically this is a meta article about the Python language summit this year
and it lists off a whole bunch of sessions each of which are covered in detail in another
article. So what I'm going to do is cover the high level bits of each one of these
main sessions. So the first one is could we have sub-interpreter support for Python?
So we were just talking about async io and stuff. One of the main problems, I don't know if I'd call
it really a problem because there's a lot of ways around it actually, but conceptions is that Python
Python's not great for threading, specifically around taking advantage of multiple cores
for CPU stuff, because of the gill.
It can have 100 threads and only one will run at a time if it's pure Python because
of the gill.
So the suggestion is, could we take this feature, which is apparently already in Python, called
subinterpreter support, to create lightweight subprocesses that run within the same process?
will allow multiple Python interpreters per process.
And there's potential for zero copy data sharing between them and things like that, which is
pretty cool.
That's interesting.
It might be interesting even for versioning, right?
Like this library requires this version where that library requires that version.
Well, you can run like maybe multiple subinterpreters.
So I don't know.
That's a whole different angle.
And it wasn't part of this presentation.
But they say the problem is that subinterpreters currently share the gill.
So the potential work is, could we make them not share the GIL so they actually can take
advantage of multiple cores?
It's becoming a thing.
So my MacBook, my new MacBook here has 12 cores as far as the OS sees it.
And if I write Python code and it takes full advantage of all the processor that it can
and single thread it, it's only 8.3% of the capacity of the CPU.
That's a lot less than 100%.
So having features like this to let you do more computation would be great.
All right, so I don't want to go too deep in these because it'll like make this an hour-long
show so I'll try to go a little quicker.
So the next one is modifying the Python object model, looking at CPython's structure.
So Carl Shapiro from Instagram talked about how they might rework the way the interpreter
interacts with classes for better performance and memory and stuff because Instagram is
all about that.
It's one of the interesting things in this article is that there was some controversy
around like the presentation and some other stuff so I'll let you read about
it. I won't bring it up here but it's worth looking at. We just talked about
the gil for parallelism and Larry Hastings has been on and off working on
this thing called the gilectomy, the removal of the gil. And the gil
basically is a thread protection around allocation in Python which means you
don't have to like take a bunch of fine-grained locks when you're allocating
new objects but because of that it means only one instruction can run at a time.
So could we take that out and have a Python that does like true parallelism?
Basically the update is not much has happened.
So for better or worse, Marietta talked about using GitHub issues for Python.
I didn't realize this wasn't already happening, but apparently it's not.
Apparently there's another site that's currently being used and trying to
move over to GitHub issues.
That's pretty cool.
Lucas talked about shortening the Python release cycle.
So right now it's on an 18 month release cycle.
So in 18 months from whenever 3.7 was out, 3.8 will be out.
Can we make that yearly? It's possibly the conversation. So you can read that.
One that you might find interesting is unplugging old batteries.
So unplugging old batteries, there's like, there's like encoding libraries for like formats
that like predate MIME and other weird type of things that are in there that nobody
likely uses anymore. So what is the process for taking stuff out of the standard library?
There's a process for getting in, but how do you get it out?
Oh, that's interesting. Yeah, a lot of things could probably be not just completely eliminated, but moved to, like, just a package or something.
Exactly. Like, this is now out. But if you need it back, you can pip install it separately. But your job is to maintain it. Like, we're not shipping it anymore. Something to that effect. It's kind of cool.
Yeah.
They talked about Linux distributions and Python 2. With Python 2 coming to end of life, what is the process for, like, basically getting those out of the Linux systems that they ship with? And how do we do that?
You talked about Python's static typing.
So there's an update on that, mostly focused on stub files.
Have you heard of stub files?
- Yeah.
- It's like the dot, dot, dot, right?
I've looked at them and they basically are
the method signature and then dot, dot, dot.
And they're not actually the implementation.
They're just saying here is the actual shape of this method.
And so what you do is they get imported alongside
of your code by things like mypy.
So they're kept in this thing called the typeshed, which is a place for third party libraries
to be in there.
So you can look through there and see things like what type of stuff, like the context
variable in what is its type definition, for example.
So there's a bunch of things with dot dot dot.
They're just like empty, not implemented sort of structures.
And so this is where a lot of the third party stuff and the standard library goes.
But they're saying, look, a lot of packages are not putting things here, like namely things
like Django and SQLAlchemy.
So there's a proposal of finding a way to bind the type information to the package and
not to the central location so that package maintainers can ship those stubs along with
their libraries.
Yeah, that would make more sense, or at least it would make some sense.
Yeah, like it'd be easier because then you don't have to say like do a PR to some other
repo, like you just put it along with your library and it's in pip.
Yeah.
So Python virtual environments, there's some debate about whether they're useful
and what we might do instead, primarily around like, if you're trying to teach
Python, you shouldn't have to start out with a 20 minute conversation of how to
do virtual environments, both on Linux, Windows, and Mac OS.
And then you can actually talk about hello world, but just how do we just do that?
So an interesting debate there.
There was some conversation around the whole new decision decision making
process now that Guido stepped down.
Another one about getting along in the Python community,
trying to make things like the dev mailer list
be more interesting and welcoming as well.
Also, finally, mentoring and diversity for Python
with Marietta and Victor Stinner as well,
two separate presentations in that general area.
So there's every single one of these things
I've talked about, there's an article about it
and more references.
And so if you want to dive into it,
it's like, it'll keep you busy for an afternoon.
- Okay, one of the things that you wrote down
but we didn't talk about was TK enter.
Oh, so the one about getting along and being more civil on dev was somebody complaining
that TK Enter is so badly out of date that it should be removed from Python, but it's
shipped with Python, which kind of brings us back to how do we unplug old batteries?
Because if people don't maintain it and it doesn't work for anyone, then why would TK
Enter be there?
So there's, we might get back on another GUI kick if we go down that too far.
Okay.
Anyway, that's what that was about.
the sort of rudeness on the mailing list was focused around TK enter.
Okay.
And whether it needs to be upgraded, removed, whatever.
Well, that is it for the Python language summit, but I thought that was super interesting.
And there's just so many looks at where people are putting their effort.
I mean, this is where the core developers are focusing their time.
So I think it's definitely worth paying attention to.
Yeah, definitely.
Cool.
All right, you got anything else you want to share with folks while we're here?
Yeah, one thing.
I noticed this from, I'm going to get his name wrong.
Anthony Sadio, code with Anthony on Twitter,
mentioned that Precommit had a huge jump in downloads on July 30th.
I first assumed that it was because we covered it or something,
but apparently it didn't line up with us covering it.
You should have covered it earlier,
could have gotten credit, but no.
But I looked at other packages and there is a weird jump in
like almost all packages downloads starting in at the end of July.
I don't have any news around that just that's weird and I wonder what's going on.
You know I wonder if that has to do with when the new PyPI launched.
Oh yeah I wonder and it's almost coincident with the pip 18 as well.
The new PyPI launched in April so yeah it could be with pip 18.
Who knows I bet it's some low-level infrastructure thing like caching got expired
and everything that had cached it everywhere got a new one or something.
Yeah, maybe they changed the way they were caching it or something.
I do remember seeing that from pip that every now and then,
like if you run a sufficiently old pip,
it'll say that it's offline cache is not compatible and it'll redownload.
So I'm wondering if in the reverse direction, when a new pip came out, that may happen.
So I bring that up so that if anybody knows what's going on,
they can get a hold of us and we can find out.
Yeah, throw it in the show notes, pythonbytes.fm/96.
Yeah, and that's one of the things that I love about this is because we can talk about things that we don't quite know about and people will correct us.
They're generally pretty nice about it too, so thank you for that.
Yeah, so one of the things that somebody mentioned, we've talked about PyCuda.
Cood-pie.
Did I get that right?
I think it's cood-pie.
Yeah.
Coo-pie.
Yeah, coo-pie.
We were guessing that maybe if you had a video card on your laptop, maybe you could use it, but we were corrected that it would have to be an Nvidia card because Cuda only runs on Nvidia.
Yeah, so apparently CUDA is a NVIDIA thing, which I didn't realize. I thought it was just a graphics card standard, but no, it's an NVIDIA thing.
So, you, this is all triggered by your question, could I do this on my MacBook or on my laptop?
If you have like a Windows or Linux laptop that has an NVIDIA card, yes. Otherwise, no. Apparently, it's the answer.
So a couple people wrote us that, wrote us and communicated that to us, so thank you all for that.
I guess if you're on a MacBook, you could get an external.
On the new ones you can do external GPUs and you could get an NVIDIA one there,
but even the one sold by Apple is actually a Radeon, so it doesn't help you.
Okay.
So, anyway, just thanks for the clarification.
Yeah, do you have anything else to add?
Nothing else. Not right now. I have some good news next week I'm going to share,
but right now nothing to say.
All right, well thanks a lot.
Just working away on projects. Yeah, thank you. Great to chat with you as always.
Yeah.
Thank you for listening to Python Bytes. Follow the show on Twitter via @PythonBytes.
That's Python Bytes as in B-Y-T-E-S.
And get the full show notes at PythonBytes.fm.
If you have a news item you want featured, just visit PythonBytes.fm and send it our
way.
We're always on the lookout for sharing something cool.
On behalf of myself and Brian Aukin, this is Michael Kennedy.
Thank you for listening and sharing this podcast with your friends and colleagues.